ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนใส่แล้วค่ะก็กลับมาเจอกับเรา 2
คน
กล่องใน B เนอะคลาสค่ะใส่แหละ
ครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันพุธค่ะ
อย่างวันนี้วันพุธนะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 17 ค่ะ
17 เดือนอะไรเดือน
พฤศจิกายนหมดหมด
เดือนพฤศจิกายนเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะ
เดือนพฤศจิกายนเป็นเดือนที่ 11 ค่ะถ้าปี
ที่พ.ต.ต.ปีพต 2  5  5564
ปีคศราคะ
ปี 6 ต.ค 2  02
12021 เนาะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไร
เมื่อวานนี้วันอังคารค่ะวันอังคารวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 16 ค่ะ 16 เดือน
เดือนพฤศจิกายนปีพตต
2564 ปีคศ
2  021 หาค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสอย่างหนาวันพฤหัสบดีวัน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 18 ค่ะเสร็จ 8 เดือน
เดือน
เมื่อปีพตตปีพศ
2564 ค่ะปีคศ 2  021
แล้วตอนนี้เนี่ยเวลากี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา 11 โมงค่ะ
11:00 น
11:00 นตรงเลยใช่ไหมเพราะว่านะ 11:00 น
ตรงใช่ไหมคะนี่ก็
11 โมงแล้ว
ก็
กินข้าวหรือยังคะ 7 โมงเนี่ยจริงนักเรียน
กินรึยังใช่ไหม
กินข้าวหรือยังค่ะใช่ค่ะวันนี้นะคะวันนี้
เนี่ยผู้หญิงน่ะก็มีคำถามอีกแล้ว
มีคำถามมาถามปูปลาร้าเออถามขอโทษขอราคา
นักเรียนประกำหมึกมันหมดหมดมีคำถาม
ครูหญิงเนี่ยจะมีถุงเนาะหนูถุง
ครูฟ้าคิดว่า
ข้างในถุงข้างในนี่ล่ะตั้งในถนนเนี่ยมี
อะไร
อะไรอยู่ในถุง
อะไหล่
ทรูฝาคิดว่า
ลิปสติก
ลิปสติกใช่ไหมคะลิฟท์อยู่ในนะ S ติกไม่
ใช่ให้อีก 1 ครั้งฟ้าคิดว่าอะไรอยู่ในถุง
ใช้ใช้พี่ใช้ข้างบนใช้กับที่หัวรุ่น
ก็
ต้องถอดสีไม้
ถุงเนี่ยยูเว้
ก่อนผู้หญิงบอกหวยอีกล่ะ
เก่งมากหวีอยู่ในถุงไหมอยู่ข้างในถุง
[เพลง]
district เนี่ยไม่ได้อยู่ในถุงละอยู่
ข้างนอกอยู่ข้างนอก
ด้วยวันนี้เนี่ยเราก็เลยจะมาคุยกันใช่ไหม
เกี่ยวกับไอ้ข้างในข้างนอกหรอให้ให้นัก
เรียนฟังหรือนั้นบอกเปปโปซิชั่นใช่ไหม
ถ่ายค่ะเป็นคำเนาะเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงจะแชร์
สกรีนนะคะนักเรียนข้อขอเวลาแป๊บนึงนายงาน
Share  screen หรอ
โอเคกู้หญิง 5 ซอยขอแชร์ริ่ง
Green
ยังไม่เห็นอะไรเนาะแต่ว่าในวีดีโอเนี่ยจะ
มาแล้วนะคะขาในรูปใช่ไหมคะในรูปเนี่ย
เอ็กครูฟ้าสามารถวงกลมได้ไหมวงกลมนายอ่ะ
กูค่ะมีปากกาค่ะความมีปากกาใช่ไหมอ่ะครู
หญิงเนี่ยนะคะก็จะมีคำถามทำไมถามครูฟ้า
ราคาจ้าในรูปใช่ไหมอ่ะคำถามแรกผู้หญิงจะ
ถามเกี่ยวกับแมว
[ปรบมือ]
แมว
[เพลง]
เนาะแมวในรูปเนี่ย
แมวอยู่ที่ไหนคะครูฟ้า
แมวอยู่ที่นี่ค่ะ
แมวอยู่บนโซฟา
ขอเสียงแมวอยู่บนโซฟาแล้วมีอะไรมีอะไรอีก
ที่อยู่บนโซฟา
หมอน
บอกอยู่บนโซฟา
ค่ะ
หมดแล้วเนาะไม่มีอะไรบนโซฟาแล้วไม่มีแล้ว
พี่โอเคต่อไปผู้หญิงก็จะถามครูฟ้าว่า
หมา
นะหมาหมา
อยู่ตรงไหนในรูปคะ
หมายอยู่ที่นี่ห่าหมาไหม
หมายอยู่ใต้โต๊ะ
เฮ้ย
มหาอยู่หมาย
ที่อยู่ใต้โต๊ะกี่ตัว
หมาอยู่ใต้โต๊ะ
2 ตัว
2 ตัวแบบฮะอันนี้หมาใช่ไหมแล้วก็มีโต๊ะ
หมาอยู่ใต้โต๊ะแล้วอะไร
อะไรอยู่บนโต๊ะ
Notebook ค่ะถ้ามี Notebook แล้วมีอะไร
อีกคะที่อยู่บนโต๊ะ
พิซซ่า
พิซซ่าอยู่บนโต๊ะ
TS ชีสอยู่บนโต๊ะอาบน้ำส้ม 9 เป็นแก้ว
น้ำแก้วน้ำอยู่บนโต๊ะค่ะเฮ้อ
มี 1  2  3  4  4 มีของ 4 อย่างอยู่บน
โต๊ะอาก็ปิด
ถูกต้องค่ะลูกค้าต่อไปผู้หญิงจะให้ครูฟ้า
หาปลาร้า
ปลาปลาปลา
อยู่ที่ไหนคะ
ปลาอยู่ที่นี่อะปลาอยู่ในน้ำ
อยู่ในน้ำแล้ว
น้ำนะอยู่ในอะไร
น้ำอยู่ในโหลโหลค่ะหน้าโหล
แบ๊วโหลโหลที่มีน้ำแล้วก็มีปลาอยู่ข้างใน
เนี่ยอยู่ที่ไหน
โหลอยู่บนโต๊ะโตอยู่บนโต๊ะนะคะอันนี้คือ
โต๊ะ
ฮัลโหลอยู่บนโต๊ะอยู่บนโต๊ะดีจ้าขาแล้วมี
อย่างอื่นอยู่บนโต๊ะกับโหลที่มีปลาไหม
อาร์มมี
ต้นไม้อยู่บนโต๊ะ
หือคนไม้อยู่บนโต๊ะ
ต้องปัดและตากคำถามต่อไป
ค่ะครูฟ้าเนี่ยบอกว่ามีแมวใช่ไหม
แมวอยู่บนโซฟา
แล้วมีอะไรอยู่ข้างๆโซฟาไม่คะ
มีอะไรอยู่ข้างๆโซฟาๆหรอคะมี
โคมไป
ก็มีคนไฟอยู่ข้างโซฟาแล้วมีอะไรอยู่อยู่
ข้างโคมไฟ
มี
อาร์ม
กีตาร์อยู่ข้างโคมไฟค่ะ
แล้ว
โคมไฟแล้วก็กีต้าร์ใช่ไหมแล้วมีอะไรอยู่
บนโคมไฟกับกีตาร์อยู่เข้าบนโคมไฟกับ
กีตาร์
Miss  Out
ทำอะไรอ่ะมีมีชั้นวางหนังสือหรืออะเดี๋ยว
นะ
ให้มันไม่
ได้ไหมครูฟ้าอ้ำ
นะโอเคมีชัดปางหนังสือ
ตรงอยู่ข้างบนโคมไฟไหม้อยู่ข้างบนโคมไฟ
กับกีตาร์ฝันควางมีชั้นหัวหน้าชั้น
อันนี้เป็นชั้นหรอมีเคยฉันนะคะแล้วบนชั้น
วางหนังสือ
มีอะไรบ้าง
บนชั้นวางหนังสือ
มีหนังสือฮะค่ะมีหนังสือกี่เล่ม
มีหนังสือ
4 เล่ม
แล้วมีอะไรอีกอยู่ข้างๆอยู่ระหว่าง
หนังสือ
มีถ้วยรางวัล
ถ้วยรางวัล
อยู่ข้างๆหนังสือหนาอยู่ตรงกลางจะอยู่
กลางวันอยู่ตรงกลาง
อยู่ระหว่างหนังสือสองเล่มหนังสืออีก 2
เล่มใช่ไหมคะฮ่าๆๆ
อีกต่อไปในโลกเนี่ยก็จะมีโอ้โหขอโทษนะคะ
นักเรียนมองไม่เห็นแล้ว
เห็นไหม
เงามีกล่อง
กล่อง
นี้ว่าจะต้องลบดีๆนะคะ
มีกล่องมีกล่องหรอ 5 ผู้หญิงจะถามว่า
มีอะไรอยู่ในกล่อง
มี
กระต่ายอยู่ในกล่องค่ะโอ๋
แล้วมีอย่างอื่นอีกไหมอยู่ในกล่องอยู่ใน
มีกล่องกับกระต่าย
เครื่องบินน้อ
คืออะไรอีกอ่ะ
มา
แล้วต่อไปนะผู้หญิงจะถามครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเห็น
นกไหมคะนก
นกป๊าเห็นนกค่ะนกอยู่ที่ไหน
นกอยู่ข้างนอกน้อไม่ได้อยู่ข้างในไม่ได้
อยู่ข้างในมายอยู่ข้างนอกบ้านแล้วมีอะไร
อยู่ข้างนอกกับนกไหมคะ
มีต้นไม้ค่ะนอน
ต้นไม้
ต้นไม้ก็อยู่ข้างนอก
อายหากคุณมาหนู
อ่ะชายแล้วก็ครูฟ้าเนี่ยบอกมีปลาใช่มั้ย
มีปลาหมอปลากับปลานี้นะคะปลาน้องมีปลามี
โหลโหลใส่ปลามีต้นไม้แล้วมีอะไรอยู่ข้าง
บนโหลใส่ปลากับต้นไม้
มี
รูปภาพค่ะหนู
รูปภาพ
แล้วข้างในรูปภาพเนี่ยเป็นรูปอะไรคะ
ข้างในหรือเปล่าภาพ
เป็นรูป
ทะเลอะ
ทะเล
แล้วมีอะไรอีกในรูปเนี่ยมีทะเลมีอะไรอีก
คะมีดวงอาทิตย์ห่าดวงอาทิตย์
แล้วอ่ะอามาโนะลงมาข้างๆกับต้นไม้นะต้น
ไม้ที่อยู่บนโต๊ะสมัยต้นไม้ที่อยู่บนโต๊ะ
เนี่ยข้างๆโต๊ะพี่มีต้นไม้มีโหลใส่ปลา
เนี่ยมีอะไรคะ
มี
ฉันวาง
ทีวีค่ะ
[เพลง]
ชั้นวางทีวีชั้นวางทีวี
แล้วบนชั้นวางทีวีมีอะไรมี
ทีวีค่ะนี่
ทีวี
ในทีวีเขียนว่าอะไร
เกียรติว่าแน็ทเหล็ก
ดูสิรีสร้าง
กริตงานแล้วที่ฉันมีชีวีเนี่ยข้างหน้า
ข้างหน้าชั้นวางทีวีมีอะไร
ข้างหน้าชั้นวางทีวีมีไม้แบบเขา
ไม้แบตแล้วมีอะไรอีกคะที่อยู่ข้างหน้าสัน
วางทีวี
กระเป๋าค่ะเอากระเป๋าเป้กระเป๋า
แล้วโต๊ะใช่ไหมโต๊ะที่มีคอมพิวเตอร์มีน้ำ
มีชีสมีพิซซ่าเนี่ยอยู่ข้างหน้า
ทีวีไหม
อยู่ข้างหน้าทีวี 5 ถุง
อยู่ข้างหน้าทีวีจ้าทรายค่ะแล้วก็โต๊ะใช่
ไหมบนโต๊ะมีชีสมีพิซซ่าใต้โต๊ะมีหมา 2
ตัว
แล้วอ่ะโอ้นี่หมาเนี่ยข้างล่างเนาะโต๊ะ
แล้วก็หมาเนี่ยอยู่บนอะไร
เอ่อ
โต๊ะกับหมาอยู่บนพรมค่ะ
พรมทรูมอยู่ใต้โต๊ะ
พรมสีอะไร
พรมสีม่วงค่ะคริสต์เรื่อง
สีม่วงค่ะ
เสื้อหนังอันนี้ก็เป็นห้องใช่มั้ยแล้วใน
ห้องเนี่ยมีหน้าต่างไหมคะ
ในห้อง
จะนะฮะ
เครื่องมือหายไปขึ้น
อยู่นี่ในห้องมี
หน้าต่างหากหามีหน้าต่าง
ปลาวางหนู
นี่แหละ
นะค่ะใส่หน้าต่างอยู่ตรงไหน
หน้าต่างอยู่ตรงกลางเขาอยู่ใกล้กับอะไร
อยู่ใกล้กับ
โซฟาน่ารักรูปภาพ
อยู่ใกล้กับโต๊ะค่ะโอ๊ะโอ๋มันวางคมไปแล้ว
บนหน้าต่าง
มีอะไรอยู่ข้างๆสองข้าง
มี
ท่าม่านค่ะ
อาม่านอ๋อ
มีถ้าบ้านอยู่ข้างๆจะวันสองค่าข้างคะแล้ว
ก็ข้างขวาอยู่บนญาติอะขณะนี้ก็เป็นห้อง
ใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วไปแล้วอ่ะเป็นของวะมีอะไรบ้างอยู่ตรง
ไหนอะไรอยู่ใกล้อะไรน้องถูกใจค่ะน้องก็
ถ้านักเรียนมีคำถามมีอะไรก็คอมเม้นต์ได้
เหมือนเดิมนะคะรัก
อย่าลืมกด like กด Share เกิด Subscribe
นะคะนักเรียนนิสัยค่ะก็จะได้มาเรียนภาษา
ไทยสนุกๆกับเราแล้วก็คุณครูหลายๆคนเป็น
ภาษาส่วนวันนี้เราสองคนก็ต้องไปก่อนเนาะ
แล้วเดี๋ยวเจอกัน bdo หน้านะคะบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะป้าเอ๋